this Christmas enter a world where more
than one wears the mask Miles Morales
you're gonna teach me to be spider-man
Peter Parker time to sway and it's a no
on the Cape I think it's cool
hey guys spider-gwen let's go it's what
a waste of energy no one's even chasing
us thanks fellas
spider Noir penny Parker and this could
not get any weirder spider-ham
it can get weird and spider-man into the
spud reverse only in theatres
my name is Miles Morales in my world
more than one where's the mask you're
like me you'll can teach me to be
spider-man this was never your city it's
mine we're gonna need backup Peter
Parker this could not get any weirder
spider-man turn invisible this is
incredible some kind of fight or flight
thing what's that I love you mom dad I
love you
this was never your city it's mine
[Music]
how am I supposed to save the whole
world
you have to think about saving one
person officer I love you hey everybody
its charlie we got a whole bunch of new
spiderman footage to break down and a
non-spoilery early review they've been
screaming giant portions of the film so
I'll do a breakdown of all that there's
a new round of that spider-man ps4 game
giveaway because it is Black Friday
everything is on sale all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
spider-man related comment on the video
I'll name a new winner at the end of
this we get a bunch of new footage of
them meeting gwen stacy trying to
assemble the team then later then trying
to infiltrate the kingpins lair Peter
Parker spider-man trying to steal some
of the snacks more of the setup for the
multiverse but he's trying to explain to
him how everything is connected with the
fries on his plate this delicious fry is
my universe this other fry is your
universe we get a lot more footage of
him inside the black comic book costume
that he makes for himself with the
graffiti spider-man logo that comes a
little bit later in the film because
first you sort of meet him you get the
setup for him at that special charter
school he meets his version of gwen
stacy that isn't spider-gwen then the
kingpin sets off the multiverse
experiment that causes the other
versions to crash land on his earth you
get all those training montage scenes of
him in the Peter Parker Halloween
costume then after he gets the big
tutorial from the other versions of
spider-man he makes his own costume like
he has that scene later in the movie
where he salutes his father in his
costume without his father knowing that
it's him saying I love you and he's like
wait what why is this tiny little
spider-man telling me that he loves me
then that meta joke tag at the end with
the fourth wall break because he's
sitting on a wall looking into frame
breaking the fourth wall so a fourth
wall break on a wall there been a couple
jokes earlier in the trailers that have
been close to fourth wall breaks but I
don't know that they're gonna do a whole
lot of Deadpool style legit fourth wall
breaking just because that's not really
a spider-man thing spider-man is a
wisecracker
but Deadpool is really the character
that's so famous for breaking the fourth
wall at every turn if you're a
PlayStation Plus member too I think that
Sony is actually handing out tickets for
early screenings of the movie but I
don't know how early they are it's
coming out the second weekend
December so it's probably for the first
week in December usually early
screenings or like the week before the
movie comes out everywhere else but
early non-spoilery review if you're not
a big Miles Morales fan this is actually
a really enjoyable spider-man movie now
this way over the top from what ultimate
spider-man was in the comics so if you
read that comic book arc that's really
just the jumping-off point for the movie
just sets the premise this is Miles
Morales he lives in what you would call
The Ultimates universe so it's based on
that Bendis storyline but the spider
verse of it all didn't come till much
later in the comics and they're doing
that in this first movie so you have to
imagine that they're overlapping his
origin story in that universe where the
original version of Peter Parker in the
Ultimate Universe gets killed by the
ultimate Goblin that inspires him to
eventually take the mantle after he gets
the spider bite and then they sort of
riff on that so it's not a page to
screen adaptation it's just a remix of
the spider versus storyline with just
crazy Easter eggs for everything you
could possibly imagine but the next best
comparison would be the Lego Batman
movie if you saw that in the way they
treated Easter eggs like it was so deep
you had to watch that three or four
times to catch everything because they
had Easter eggs for every iteration of
Batman in the movies the TV shows in the
comics it's the same deal for Spider Man
into the spider burst it is an endurance
test of Easter egg hunting so if you
really like that part of comic book
movies you'll have your work cut out for
you trying to find everything when you
see this if you're a big Marvel movie
fan and you were a little turned off by
the tonal messiness of venom how it just
felt like a couple of different Franken
movies just cobbled together like they
were trying to make a rated R film but
then it turned into a pg-13 film and
just everybody felt like they were in a
slightly different movie animation by
comparison is incredibly precise and
because it takes so much longer to make
it they spend that much more time trying
to get it right so just on a technical
level it's a much more polished film it
feels like this is what they intended to
make the entire time not something that
they ended up with at the end of a long
process even if you're not a huge fan of
the Miles Morales character is still
just so much fun to watch him interact
with the other universe versions of
spider-man like the midlife crisis 40
something Peter Parker penny Parker
Peter Parker spider-man noir it's just
the beginning obviously they can get so
much crazier because it's animation they
can do whatever they want to with the
sequels there's no limitation to what
they can do or which other
characters they can use in sequels it's
like the spider-man games like just have
much more powerful storytelling tools at
their disposal in related Marvel stuff
there's a rumor that Marvel will not
release The Avengers 4 trailer next week
because there's a different Disney
trailer that's dropping that might be
Artemis Fowl there was someone that came
up with an interesting theory about dr.
Strange's 1 in 14 million plan being
tied to the Avengers 4 trailer release
but the theory states that the countdown
clock that they have running on that
untitled Avengers website it just
accounts out running to midnight the
night of the Avengers 4 premiere next
year so this person thinks that when the
countdown clocks hits that number the
Doctor Strange spat out it was 14
million 605 when the countdown clock
reads that that's when the trailer is
going to release but even though that
sounds like a cool Easter Egg for Marvel
to drop the Avengers 4 trailer on the
problem is is that when the countdown
clock reads 14 million 605 that'll be
December 13th at 6 minutes past midnight
and Marvel isn't really known for
dropping big major first trailers at 6
minutes after midnight that is super
early typically what they've done the
last three years all the way back to
Civil War is that they release it early
in the week on a big new show like Good
Morning America between like 6:00 and
9:00 in the morning when most of the
world is awake and walking around and
able to actually watch the trailer like
they're not gonna wake you up with a big
trailer so that's why I don't believe
this December 13th theory and you have
to remember this Sony is probably gonna
want to promote spider-man far from home
back in 2016 they released the first
Home Coming trailer a couple months
after they finished filming so pretty
easy prediction that they'll do
something similar for spider-man far
from home and they also have another
spider-man movie they're releasing
spider-man into the spider-verse that's
releasing December 13th so it will be
kind of weird for Marvel to jack their
movie premiere to promote their movie
over there spider-man Tom Horn film I
know it's kind of confusing but it just
feels like when Marvel drops The
Avengers 4 trailer that will probably be
the only big trailer they released that
week and they still have Captain Marvel
to promote - there'll be more footage
for that before the end of the year
Marvel's official Spanish foreign
language account has been tweeting
mysterious count
promos of all the Avengers intros so you
can kind of tell round-the-world they're
building for a big reveal coming up
[Music]
so when your theory crafting about when
all these trailers are dropping just
assumes that nobody is gonna step on
each other's toes
so Avengers 4 footage will probably not
drop in the same week as new Captain
Marvel footage or new spider-man far
from home footage Kevin Feige confirmed
that we get the trailer before the end
of the year but don't be surprised if
they don't release it next week and it
winds up being sometime early in
December congratulations amazing Nino
gear the giveaway winner from my last
big video please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details click here to watch Hugh Jackman
talk about Deadpool Wolverine crossover
during Avengers and Marvel phase 4 and
click here to rewatch that new Lion King
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you